[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
wieso sage ich eigentlich immer den
gleichen anfang
ich meine ihr seid herzlich willkommen
zum event hallo willkommen in meiner
küche
das hat sich nicht so egal wie wir
belassen hallo herzlich willkommen zum
style ist heute wird bei uns gegrillt
und ich möchte euch in diesem video weil
ihr immer wieder in den stories auch
nachfragt was wir dann immer so grillen
zeigen was wir heute machen und zum
einen ist es jetzt heute wie so ne art
menü zum anderen könnt ihr es benutzen
wenn er sagt wir wollen vegan oder
vegetarisch grillen
denn das meiste wird auf dem grill
zubereitet oder er sagt wir wollen ganz
klassisch grillen und alles was du heute
hier zubereitet ist dann sozusagen eine
grill beilage also je nachdem wie viele
personen ihr seid was ihr alles
zubereitet ist es eben eine beilage oder
sogar ein hauptgericht und ich mache es
immer ganz gerne so ich mache dinge die
ich dann auch noch die nächsten 14 tage
essen kann also wenn wir freitags oder
samstags grillen dann haben wir sonntags
auch noch was davon und es wird einfach
alles nicht schlecht und man hat eben
ganz wenig arbeit damit was wird zuerst
über machen ist baguettes magisches
baguette weil es einfach mega einfach
ist und es ist einfacher als brot kaufen
zu gehen denn ihr braucht im prinzip nur
etwas hefe und zucker wasser mehl und
salz darf war es das rezept gibt schon
auf einem kanal und ich habe ziele die
doppelte menge habe hier die hefe schon
zerbröselt und gibt es jetzt mit dem
zucker hier in der schüssel in die
schiffe dann direkt das wasser dazu und
ihr könnt das magische baguettes
entweder ganz klassisch und hell machen
oder ihr könnt sagen verfeinert und so
machen wir es auch gerne also je nachdem
was ich gerade da habe in der
weihnachtszeit haben auch gerne bärlauch
parkett gemacht ihr könnt auch kleine
brötchen draus machen und
frühstücksbrötchen zb oliven mit dazu
geben also da könnte er wirklich den
geschmack komplett umwandeln wenn ihr
die zutaten verrührt habt kommt im
prinzip nur noch das mehl dazu und das
besondere ist dass man es eben nicht
kneten muss also man kann wirklich alles
mit dem koch oder backofen verrühren
salz kommt auch rein
ich gebe auch manchmal gerne chili dazu
aber nur in die hälfte für die kinder in
die andere hälfte also nicht für dich
und da meine ich doch gehört und heute
machen wir weil wir gerade schnitt noch
im garten haben schnitt noch baguette
unternehmen bereite schnittlauch was
auch mega lecker ist interest zwiebeln
getrocknete tomaten also tobt euch da
ruhig aus
[Musik]
und ich hatte hier so den teich am rand
runter da einfach nicht so austrocknet
dann ist mein brot tag schon mal
gerichte das baguette ist sozusagen fast
fertig steckt jetzt einfach ab und kann
jetzt bis zu zwei stunden aufgehen
lassen
wenn es mal schnell gehen muss so machen
wir es meistens gebe ich einfach ohne
deckel in den backofen denn da kann ich
die der stufe 1 stellen auf 34 grad und
dann ist das baguette im prinzip schon
also der teig schon innerhalb von 30 bis
60 minuten fertig da ist wirklich
einfach nur wichtig gar nicht so lange
kneten wirklich nur rühren und dann darf
der teig einfach schön aufgehen ihr
könnt es auch schon am tag vorher zu
bereiten und dann aber im kühlschrank
aufgehen lassen mit deckel okay und
jetzt geht's bei uns direkt weiter ich
nicht mal alle zutaten und zeigt euch
weiß heute noch so alles gibt
[Musik]
brauchen wir mal so viel kino blogger
alles beim grillen dann geb dir einfach
die knoblauchknollen in ein glas
verschließt geschüttelt und dann ist ihr
geschäft
[Musik]
jetzt kommt als nächstes die champignon
ferne
das mache ich dann immer ganz gerne in
so einem großen bräter den kann ich
nämlich entweder auf dem herd benutzen
auf der kochstelle oder draußen auf dem
grill
dafür habe ich jetzt hier eigentlich
schon längst da könnt ihr weiße oder
eben auch dunkle nehmen zwei zwiebeln
zwei riesen knoblauchzehen etwas thymian
habe ich noch salz pfeffer und chili und
olivenöl und es lässt sich auch super
vorbereiten und vor allem auch schnell
zubereiten ist einfach die champignons
halbieren die kann ich jetzt hier auch
schon mal rein geben
ich könnte auch alternativ einfach so
eine grillschale benutzen die aber eben
zuerst damit das fett nicht raus tropft
die mag ich echt super gerne denn wenn
wir sie nicht komplett auf essen heute
kann ich sie morgen immer noch essen
wie so eine art antipasti dann auch kalt
als salat oder ich mich dann zum
beispiel rucola noch mal dazu also die
kann man wirklich individuelle noch mal
variieren die zwiebel und die
knoblauchzehen schneide ich jetzt auch
die zwiebel einfach in hall bringe und
die knoblauchzehen in feine scheiben
dann etwas salz um chili pfeffer den mal
ich jetzt aber etwas grob ich liebe
zwiebeln aber ich hasse dich zu
schneiden
olivenöl dazu
gut durchmischen und dann ist die
pfannen schon mal gerichtet und ich kann
mich um die nächste beilage kümmern oder
ums nächste gericht majoran oder oregano
oder thymian was auch irgendwas ist ich
glaube es ist aber tatsächlich denn ich
habe kein majoran angepflanzt das muss
keiner sein
das gebe ich erst zum schluss mit dazu
haben jetzt einfach jetzt auf dem grill
gleich nicht verbrennt lotte shopping um
wanne pflege ich kurz weiter jetzt gibt
es als beilage noch kartoffeln
rosmarinkartoffeln und da hab ich jetzt
kleine kartoffeln bereits auch gewaschen
so müsst ihr sie auch nicht schälen und
die werde ich jetzt als nächstes zu
bereiten weil ich die im ofen vorgabe
damit sie auf dem grill einfach nicht so
viel zeit in anspruch nehmen also ich
habe jetzt zwei kilo kartoffeln drei
große knoblauchzehen oder sechs kleine
etwas olivenöl rosmarin aus dem garten
und salz und pfeffer
ich finde mehr brauchen kartoffeln
sowieso nicht je nach größe halbieren
sie jetzt einfach die kleinen lasse ich
jetzt aber so im ganzen
jetzt hier einen großen topf bzw eine
pfanne
denn den kann ich jetzt vorher in den
ofen schieben und später einfach auch
auf dem grill benutzen
ich benutze es jetzt gleich mit deckeln
im ofen damit die kartoffeln vorgang und
später natürlich ohne deckel damit ich
das grill aroma auch in den kartoffeln
haben
[Musik]
die knoblauchzehen auch noch ganz kurz
halbieren oder vierteln knoblauch
einfach wenn es im ganzen ist und dann
in verbindung mit dem öl und dann baktus
oder kaltes auf dem herd und backofen
uhr laufen grill draußen maker salz und
pfeffer rosmarin alles vermischen und
dann kommt es wie gesagt in den backofen
wird vorgegart und ich kann ihnen da
zwischenzeit schon mal andere dinge zu
bereiten und vorbereiten
das ist eigentlich schon und gericht für
sich
einfach lecker geschmack studios marin
kartoffeln
ja ich finde das ist einfach so die
perfekte kombination hatte das bild also
eigentlich bereitet einfach nur
kartoffeln zu mit rosmarin und fertig
und knoblauch mehr braucht man nicht
[Musik]
übrigens auch gleichzeitig ein peeling
für die hände so olivenöl salz und
pfeffer
[Musik]
bei uns darf schafskäse auf dem grill
auch nicht fehlen also gibt es jetzt
noch schafskäse
ich mache heute übrigens eine riesige
menge denn wir essen später alle im team
also nicht wundern dass hier alles in
kiloweise menge zubereitet wird
normalerweise wenn wir jetzt nur zu
viert sind dann mache ich auch echt nun
viertel davon
okay manchmal übertreibt es trotzdem
aber wir haben danach drei tage was
davon
also ich nehme jetzt dafür schafskäse
rote zwiebeln knoblauch zehn kleine
cocktailtomaten pepperoni etwas berg
bohnenkraut olivenöl salz und pfeffer
und kleine schwarze oliven
also ich nenne jetzt ihr zuerst die
tomaten würde ich sagen die zwiebeln und
schneidet sie einfach in hall bringe
grillen ist so cool weil man wirklich
alles perfekt vorbereiten kann und
freund von uns bei denen waren wir bis
zum letzten jahr eigentlich immer jedes
jahr zum grillen dieses jahr weiß ich
nicht ob es wird kochen und da war es
immer so die machen dann immer vorspeise
zwischengang hauptspeise und es sind
dann wirklich mehrere gänge man sitzt da
und kann irgendwie vier bis fünf stunden
richtig schön grillen und dann macht
auch finde ich noch mehr spaß weil man
einfach immer wieder was kleines ist und
draußen sitzt und schön in der sonne und
ja ich bereits jetzt gleich alles auf
einmal zu weil wir im team hier aber
immer sehr hungrig sind und alles auf
einmal wollen aber das eignet sich auch
alles hervorragend wirklich um ebendiese
zwischen gänge zu machen kam er wirklich
so den schafskäse vorweg machen und dann
die kartoffeln und als hauptgang mit dem
spargel zum beispiel zwiebeln jetzt gar
nicht so fein sondern eher grob
schneiden die knoblauchzehe in scheiben
es kommt hier erstmal alles in der
schüssel dafür rühre ich jetzt nämlich
alles also auch die tomaten die peperoni
laster auch ruhig zutaten weg die ihr
nicht mögt oder den welche dazu die ihr
gerne mit das kann ich jetzt schön im
olivenöl erstmal verrühren
hier noch direkt ins pfeffer dazu und
nur ein bisschen salz denn ich habe ja
noch den schafskäse und die peperoni
dies ja auch witzig werks wohnend kraut
dass sich so ein bisschen ab und dann
kommt in einer offen und grill geeignete
form
ich lass das jetzt hier drauf ich nehme
dir diese vier pfännchen damit ich das
später dann auf dem tisch schön
verteilen kann
aber wir können doch alles in eine
schale geben ich finde das sieht schon
ziemlich cool aus also vegan machen
möchte gerne so aber mit schafskäse
natürlich auch mega mega lecker und vor
allem unsere eller liebt gebackenen
schafskäse
ich weiß da gibt es eine öffnung aber
meine hände sind fertig den käse gebe
ich jetzt einfach hier in die schüssel
wenn es ihnen im rest fett und legt
ihnen dann hier drauf
das sind gerichte die schmecken gut und
sie sehen gut aus weil uns grüner
spargel vom grill mega gut schmeckt gibt
es jetzt für euch das rezept den habe
ich auch schon ganz oft zubereitet und
vor allem schmeckt er am nächsten tag
auch noch richtig gut wenn nicht sogar
noch besser weil er dann richtig durch
zählt also könnten kalt essen oder warm
essen ist der hammer dafür nehme ich ein
kilo grünem spargel etwas orangensaft
olivenöl knoblauch granatapfel ganz
wichtig salz und pfeffer und pinienkerne
hier werde jetzt zuerst einmal außer den
spargel habe ich schon gewaschen und
star entfernt die einfach diese holzigen
enden am besten gar nicht wegschneiden
sondern brechen und da wo
auseinanderbricht dass es praktisch der
holze gepard den brauche ich nicht und
das ist der schöne frische pasta
ausgeharrt entschuldigung hier ist
sollte man das sieht man das komplette
dinge soll sich murat macht schon das
feuer dann kann ich hier die pinienkerne
schon mal in einer pfanne rasten ohne
fett bisserl egger duften zu bekommen
sind besseres aroma
immer wieder so ein bisschen schwenken
und dann kann ich schon mal die marinade
zu bereiten
ich nehme den granatapfel und nicht
durchschneiden sondern erstmal nur für
das wort morath steckenmesser
aufgefallen
ok also nur außen die schale einritzen
und jetzt einfach in die hand nehmen und
mit einer schöpfkelle oder espresso
draufschlagen und dann fallen die kerne
raus perfekt tauschen statt so olivenöl
soll die sauerei freuen hier gemacht ob
ich los heftig putzes gleich weg dann
den knoblauch natürlich in scheiben
ich habe überall knobloch traum aber
zumindest essen wir alle davon dann
stürzt den anderen nicht und deshalb
vampire weg dann salz und pfeffer ein
bisschen schwenken oder haben die
pinienkerne bisschen farbe bekommen
die kommen jetzt noch ganz warm dazu und
fertig ist muss ich im prinzip nur noch
den spargel auf dem grill grill also gar
nicht lange da furcht bissfest bleiben
ist er anders als weißer spargel und
dann kommt er einfach mit in diese
marinade einen habe ich noch einen noch
und zwar in warmen tomaten und dann
reicht's auch glaube ich denn ansonsten
streng dass wieder völlig den rahmen an
torwart thomas cocktailtomaten olivenöl
knoblauch natürlich senfkörner treffer
eine zitrone
da unbedingt darauf achten dass sie auch
die schale zum verzehr geeignet ist denn
ich brauche auch die zitronenschale salz
und wenn ihr möchtet chili das könnt ihr
wenn ihr jetzt keinen platz mehr auf dem
grill habt auch gerne auf dem herd zu
bereiten dann habt ihr einfach so einen
schönen warmen tomaten salat
ich gucke jetzt gleich wie es draußen
passt wie gesagt wenn ihr es in mehreren
gängen macht dann könnt ihr alles offen
grill zubereiten ansonsten nimmt auch
backofen und den herd mit dazu olivenöl
habe ich jetzt hier schon in meiner
pfanne dann nehme ich die knoblauchzehe
also wir sind knoblauch liebhaber ich
hoffe ihr auch bringt halt vorlegen das
mag die knoblauchzehe kommt jetzt hier
rein wenn ihr jetzt dritten auf dem herz
so bereitet könnte gern die
knoblauchzehe schon mal ein bisschen
rösten ich brauche jetzt hier an der
stelle nicht dann kommen die gewaschenen
tomaten hier rein einfach im ganzen am
besten vorher noch ein bisschen
abtrocknen aber ich mach das so das ist
schonmal part 1 und dann mache ich hier
jetzt das dressing rein da kommen jetzt
die senfkörner dazu pfeffer etwas salz
jetzt die zitronenschale abreiben und
dazu geben dann den saft
perfekt das ist also das dressing und
die tomaten werden jetzt mit dem
olivenöl und knoblauch schön gegrillt
und das dressing kommt dann später über
die warmen tomaten die chili die nehme
ich auch noch mit dazu die könnt ihr
nehmen müsst ihr aber nicht ab so ein
bisschen chili rainer schärfe ist schon
gut aber ich glaube ich servierte ich
einfach separaten kann sich jeder selber
chillida zu geben oder eben auch
weglassen kann ist jetzt fertig ich
mache jetzt gleich das brot fertig alles
andere ist gerichtet und dem rathaus
schon mal anfangen dem spargel zu krank
ich habe den teig jetzt zum schlusskurs
abgedeckt weil ich ihn schon aus dem
ofen rausgeholt habe und jetzt kann ich
einfach zwischendurch mal das paket zu
bereiten entweder macht ihr jetzt sechs
große paket oder ihr nehmt etwas
kleinere förmchen ihr könnt auch
brötchen machen ihr könnt auch komplett
ohne baguette form arbeiten
wichtig ist ihr nehmt jetzt am besten
zum blech ganz viel mehr drauf denn das
ist ja sehr flüssig und den kippe ich da
jetzt drauf stelle kaderschnitt lang
ich habe es hier einfach die doppelte
menge das grundrezept gemacht was
bereits existiert in meine app oder auf
dem blog und jetzt mail oben drüber denn
ihr formt den jetzt auch gar nicht mit
den händen
ich nehme jetzt hier so kleine brötchen
backt förmchen aber auch große
eigentlich jetzt gerne diese kleinen
gemacht aber ich habe nur zwei bleche
davon dass genehmigte großen jetzt
wirklich gar nicht großartig den teig
bewegen und einfach in die förmchen
einlegen
trifft eigentlich aufgeben werden schöne
dicke paket also kleine mini budget und
wenn ihr sie ohne dieses black pack
könnt ihr sie zum beispiel so einfach
aus lochblech legen und dann packen sie
eben ohne form das geht auch so bekommen
sie einfach von unten schon mal diese
typische baguette form
[Musik]
so sehen sexy paus entstehen nämlich
jetzt noch hier rein und dann direkt
sind in heißen backofen bei heißluft 240
grad oder umluft oder ober unterhitze am
besten mit dampf stoss am sonst nehmen
sie einfach ein schälchen mit wasser und
stellt dazu und dann sind gleich
debattiert fertig
[Musik]
und das übrige mail kommt einfach wieder
zurück damit aber keine teig reste drin
sind einfach kurz durch 7
dann habe da auch nichts verschwendet
[Musik]
also den spargel immer einfach nur schön
bissfest garen wirklich nur 23 minuten
oder auch vier fünf wochen
aber ich mag das ja da muss bis haben es
bis haben dadurch sollen kommt da gleich
die marinade darüber dass wirklich nur
vier minuten der könnten auch gleich
noch klein schneiden aber ich lasse ihn
glaube ich jetzt erstmal im ganzen los
morath los morata ich geb dir gleich was
und es war die kartoffeln die sind schon
vorgegart schön auf den deckel drauf
dass ich so ein bisschen rauch aroma
bekommt
[Musik]
die champignons von der wir jetzt auch
einfach gegrillt bis sie gar erst dann
gebe ich jetzt auch für erst den deckel
drauf dann gab es ein bisschen schneller
und immer wieder schön umrühren
[Musik]
jetzt immer fertig jetzt ist alles
bereit
wir können essen und wie gesagt das
meiste hallo wir warten jetzt auf alle
wie gesagt dass meistergrad die
champignons die tomaten der spargel die
kartoffeln kann man auch alles noch
morgen erst wenn was übrig bleibt aber
eigentlich murat war dass unsere gäste
team auf unser thema also wie gesagt die
vorbereitung ist hier alles und jetzt
haben wir alle hunger und essen habe
jetzt eigentlich erwartet dass das sagen
spaß wo ist das fleisch wurst fleisch
aber ich mag für spargel als super
fleisch natürlich mit ins fleisch esse
ich liebe jetzt wäre es gut gewesen
rumpsteak zu haben oder an und rico oder
eine cd oder mein gott nein also hier
können so wirklich super vegetarisch
grillen oder sogar vegan grillen also
bis auf den schafskäse ist alles sogar
vegan und ihr könnte aber ihr könnt auch
sagen ich nehme jetzt champagner oder
die tomate und macht dann eben noch
fleisch dazu also so eine kleine
anregung für euch viel spaß zum
nachmachen und wir essen jetzt okay wir
keinen anderen
als wir jetzt das erste mal gedreht
haben war es extrem schwer
das ganze fleisch alles harte wochen und
das diese gerüche gegrillte spießer etc
aber ich muss sagen ich kann das nichts
du kannst vegan genauso gut grillen wie
mit vielleicht gar kein problem so vegan